near the end of my preview of lego star
wars the skywalker saga i started
laughing hard enough that i had to pause
and make sure my discord microphone was
muted so that the company rep wouldn't
hear me and think i'd lost my mind i was
playing through episode 4 a new hope and
obi-wan snooping around the death star
was almost spoiled by the untimely
boisterous arrival of c-3po and r2d2 the
nearby stormtroopers wandered off after
briefly investigating one commenting
that maybe the noise had been another
drill after obi-wan ensured the coast
was clear he turned to address his droid
companions revealing that c-3po had
found and activated an electric drill
oh my friend must be swift and silent
it's such a silly low hanging fruit of a
pun yet it took all i could muster to
stifle my laughter long enough to mute
myself i still don't know exactly why
that particular joke is the one that got
my traditionally stoic gamer face to
break though i'd wager it was the slow
pan to see threepio as a droid his head
is always frozen in the same appearance
which in the context of this particular
scene was used to great effect to
emulate the look of a shocked deadpan
expression regardless the scene was all
i needed to see to know that the
skywalker saga may turn out to be pretty
good nice come on
[Music]
hmm
it's them blast them i've been playing
lego star wars since the first in the
series which my sister and i got as a
gift alongside our first console a
nintendo gamecube as my mom and dad
didn't know much about video games they
didn't know that the gamecube needed a
memory card to retain game data and so
my sister and i spent the rest of the
week off of school playing lego star
wars and having to start over with zero
progress every time we turned the
console off and yet i loved it enjoying
how well the game reinterpreted star
wars to be humorously goofy
goofy storytelling has been the biggest
strength of the lego star wars series as
it is for many of the lego games and the
best entries are the ones that manage to
retell the stories of their source
material in a way that feels like the
source has always been a comedy that's
not too difficult with star wars it's an
absurd science fantasy franchise that
requires only the gentlest of pushes to
transform into something ridiculous if
my preview is any indication the team
behind the skywalker saga understands
that with the core story beats all
seemingly remaining intact the changes
that it does make are like the
aforementioned drill pun noticeable but
still small i think this is ultimately
going to be an excellent way to enjoy
star wars regardless of whether you're a
long time fan or a new face in the
galaxy far far away
well my little friend you've got
something jammed in here real good
are you on a star cruiser
you're my only hope the skywalker saga
is not a collection of lego star wars
the video game lego star wars 2 the
original trilogy and lego star wars the
force awakens this entirely new entry
and developer tt games series features
brand new and original levels cut scenes
voice acting hub areas and gameplay
mechanics each of the nine episodes can
be played in any order and the
storylines of each episode have been
tweaked to incorporate details from
beyond the nine mainline movies for
instance the opening of a new hope has
been adjusted so that the episode begins
with the final moments of rogue one a
star wars story that means there are
plenty of easter eggs and references for
long time star wars and lego star wars
fans to point out but each storyline is
seemingly kept pretty tight and only
covers the main plot lines for each
episode this is still a game aimed at
kids so you don't need an encyclopedic
knowledge of the past 45 years of star
wars to understand what's going on
tt games has taken steps to evolve the
gameplay of the lego star wars games in
this latest entry as well a new
over-the-shoulder perspective and cover
system aligns the skywalker saga to be a
bit more like your traditional third
person shooter a combo and block system
also allows you to pull off a variety of
moves and melee and lightsaber combat
these new mechanics don't change the
lego star wars formula as much as
they've been advertised to you can still
very easily take out whole legions of
enemies by fighting out in the open
given that everyone you fight aims like
a stormtrooper negating the need for
cover and spamming random combos is
still an incredibly effective strategy
when you have a lightsaber in your hand
enemies can block you but i didn't go up
against anyone in the preview that
encouraged me to be strategic in how i
fought so as cool as it can be to
occasionally engage in these systems
they feel superfluous they aren't
detracting from the overall experience
of what it's like to play a lego star
wars game but they aren't actually
adding anything either and that left me
wondering why they were even there in
the first place if anything the
skywalker saga seems to most excel in
its puzzles all characters are divided
into one of nine classes jedi hero
scavenger scoundrel bounty hunter
villain darkseid astromech droid and
protocol droid and each possesses unique
movement mechanics and abilities that
allow them to navigate around different
types of obstacles and interact with the
environment in various ways a jedi can
use july mine trick to control the
actions and thoughts of other characters
for example while a villain has the
special clearance to access specific
computers the skywalker saga's best
puzzles task you with figuring out how
to mix and match these abilities for
instance at obi-wan kenobi you can use
jedi mind trick to take control of a
stormtrooper and then maneuver them over
to a computer to access it and open a
gate that's halting your progress beyond
the more rudimentary puzzles each of the
skywalker saga's 45 levels also has
three challenges which encourages you to
replay levels and discover clever ways
of circumnavigating problems and the
first level of a new hope for example
you are presented with some lego bricks
that allow you to build a way to break
into the room you need to get into which
is filled with stormtroopers or douse
the flames leading into an adjacent
hallway you can't do both you have to
pick doing the latter leads to a
terminal that can be hacked into which
opens an airlock and jettisons the room
of stormtroopers out into space allowing
you to forego a direct confrontation
not all of these challenges are so
clear-cut either or situations though
later in a new hope when han luke and
chewie are sneaking into the detainment
level of the death star to save leia i
found a way to dim the lights and then
use han's special ability as a scoundrel
to deduce how to drop the
short-circuited overhead lights on the
guards doing so allowed me to get
through the encounter without the need
for a fight not actually how that scene
in a new hope plays out but it felt
pretty cool to pull off nonetheless and
i still ended up needing to jump into
the trash compactor to escape so overall
events still played out as they should
what an incredible smell you've
discovered
the game doesn't highlight the locations
of these challenges motivating you to
pay attention to how your lego
surroundings have been built and how to
utilize the unique skill sets of your
party to best pull it apart or build
around it the solutions aren't obvious
and are enjoyable to think over making
them rewarding to solve hey there's
people down here you know overall i
finished my preview of lego star wars
the skywalker saga a bit perplexed over
the changes it makes to the lego star
wars games combat but pleased to see
that the series innate silliness and
goofy nature is intact i was pleasantly
surprised at how much i enjoyed the
puzzles especially the episode specific
challenges that are built around
characters unique class skills i'm
looking forward to playing the full game
which launches on april 5th if you're
also looking forward to the skywalker
saga subscribe to the channel to keep up
to date on our coverage of the game and
be sure to like this video if you
enjoyed it and want to see us do more
previews going forward
[Music]
you